the quadratic expressions 4x squared
plus 12x plus 9 and 4x squared minus 9
share a common binomial factor
what binomial factor do they share and i
encourage you to pause the video see if
you can figure it out
so let's do this by taking each of these
expressions and trying to factor them
into binomials and then see if they
share a common binomial factor i guess
they do share wanted to figure out which
ones which one they actually share so
let's focus first on this 4x squared
plus 12x
plus 9.
so the first thing that might jump out
at you
is well let's see i have a 4 here this
coefficient on the x squared term that's
a perfect square i could write the
entire 4x squared term i could rewrite
that as 2x
to the second power
then out here i have
a constant term the 9 that also is a
perfect square i could rewrite that as 3
squared and you could say well gee what
you know does this does this fit the
pattern of a perfect square polynomial
in order for it to fit the pattern of a
perfect square polynomial the
coefficient here on the x term would
need to be two times the product of this
two and this three
and it is indeed two times the product
of two and three it is two times six so
we could write this we could write this
part right over here as 2
times
2 times
that 2
times 3
times that 3
x x
and then of course we have to add these
three things together
so plus plus
and so just like that we can recognize
hey this is a this is a perfect square
polynomial right over here and if what
i'm what i'm saying right now sounds
like a little bit of voodoo i encourage
you to watch some of the videos on
perfect square trinomials perfect square
polynomials some of the last few videos
in this progression so this thing can be
can be rewritten as the same thing as
2x
plus 3
2x plus 3 squared
2x plus 3 squared once again because
it's of the form you have the entire 2x
squared here you have the entire you
have the 3 squared here and then this
middle term is 2 times the product of
these two terms right over here and so
it definitely it definitely fit the
pattern so there you have it we factored
the first expression and now let's try
to factor the second expression and
immediately when you see this one it
looks like it's a difference of squares
so this one right over there looks like
a difference of squares to me
this we can rewrite as
2 x
squared
minus
minus let me pick a nice color
minus 3 squared so minus 3 squared this
is a difference of squares we've seen
multiple times how to factor difference
of squares if this is once again looks
foreign to you i encourage you to watch
those videos and we explain how that
works and why it works but this is going
to be when you have something of the
form a squared minus b squared it's
going to be equal to a plus b times a
minus b so this is going to be equal to
let me just put the two binomials right
over here so it's going to be a plus b
times a
minus b
so this is going to be
2x
plus 3 times 2x minus 3.
so 2x plus 3 times 2x minus 3.
and so what is their common binomial
factor
well they both involve when you when you
factor them out they both have a
binomial factor of 2x plus 3. this one
right over here we could rewrite if we
want we could rewrite it as 2x plus 3
times 2x plus 3. that might have been
somewhat obvious to you already so 2x
2x
then
you have plus 3 plus 3 these two are
equivalent and so you see we see that we
share
we in both in both of these we share at
least one or we share exactly one two x
plus three so that's the binomial factor
that they share two x plus three